oh I'm doing here I don't know what I'm
doing here
and if I've cut this up then huh [ __ ] ow
damn it
Oh [ __ ] you get to die a lot you
only die once yo dough as they say that
should be the new anthem it's kind of
equivalent sorta okay ah man else the
second time that guy got me good so that
shadow guy in particular is very
precarious then very good at what he
does
I have any bullets left oh hi I have
room for one more and I think I've
killed every single one of you [ __ ]
maybe you're not like pick the keys off
the corpses guys kill down well this
this game may end with me not finishing
it because I can't find a single damn
thing that I need was up there I stacked
something to get up there I love to get
up there I don't think there's anything
stackable that's like you why does that
keep happening
hmm why does that keep happening I
really would like to know there's some
weight there was like a gurney in the
other room if I can get there and like
one of the tiles is loose and movies
blue you how about this big syringe
anything nope all right yeah no okay
all right you know I didn't want to go
anyway you can look no there's nothing
here
there is nothing what the [ __ ] Jesus
balls dude god dammit huh it's just I
don't expect you to be there because I
thought I cleared everything out goddamn
it huh at least your store these
dumpsters are here that's something I
least I've not seen anything if I missed
something guys please berate me in the
comments like just rip me a new [ __ ]
in the comments if I'm missing something
cuz this is obviously like just go back
to singing my lustrous clear career in
singing Christmas carols to Santa that
worked out well for me
if YouTube ever fails and so I'm gonna
move in do it'll be good okay I think I
think it was meant like six bullets six
guys oh don't start the heart bump
thumpy thump again no all right you know
and if I can't find it in the next two
minutes I'm just gonna call it quits
because it's just it's kind of
ridiculous if you ask me what doors
being locked like a-holes maybe now that
I've killed everyone maybe something
happened like I don't know maybe who
knows maybe now big shadow guys Ben awk
who's gonna call me Larry and then take
me to the back room and make me drink to
forget gross maybe things could happen
heard that something else happen yeah I
didn't even notice that the music cut
out probably cuz Ray's that last jump
skier happened his eyes really
jump-scares this is all son there's a
dude and he wasn't supposed to be there
anyway maybe something happened maybe
after I killed them all now this one
with blood will be unlocked there's
something I don't know nope
no why would that be thing why me
yes so stupid I'm just a dude with dummy
abdomin dick walking around haha
burning in his Dana claws slowly uh-huh
ha ha ha I'll break you I'm gonna break
your game come on markable are game
breaking powers unite get me through
this bear get me through yeah
no no okay my powers have failed me
everybody I'm just not as strong as I
thought I was uh huh oh god damn it how
long was that there you guys are
probably happy that I didn't give up but
probably very very mad at me that I
missed that one okay I found a key and
it was in a really obvious place but it
was actually back in the area that I
didn't check I was I said I was gonna
stop but then I kept going on oh I found
it I got it
alright yes I did is it not for that one
okay but for one of these one up here uh
yeah oh yeah
yes yes I did I did it guys
I did I hope there's an on another
shadow dude up here cuz Oh God
morons
uh what was that about dying
cuz I'd rather not if it's y'all's name
I'd rather be alive in there I do I
don't think I want to know hey Lou
anything you is it something of import
about ah haha okey whoa what are you you
ballerina [ __ ] got no no no no no no
don't let me die
ah [ __ ] I've had yeah break it bears oh
yeah
oh God die who cares I got the key I
don't think I'll need another oh my god
don't wait for me to save my game I can
help us hmm
Oh God what was that thing okay your
keys not to there but key maybe be
downstairs oh man good no no no what are
you doing I got a key
uh okay whatever you know I guess it
must be to uh your you to the right here
I'm in here than I need Polly not in the
first one know about put a whole lot of
nope on that one how about a big new
look what I prefer forget who wants a
minute I goddamn it mother humping
[ __ ] [ __ ] humper goddamn it I'm
cursing a lot more that's nicer than I
haven't passed but oh you I'm dead I'm
dead I'm dead I'm dead
I'm Dedham get caught on our door you
bastard oh you these story Oh Wayne tieu
just a slight Eve slippery ugh um okay
so back in I don't know what I'm
supposed to do I have a key
I got a key and I can't open anything
with it like the two doors that I know
the only other ones in this area that
are locked still it doesn't work do them
why oh no you know what
oh is that one of these is locked oh all
of these are locked
oh oh okay but one is more locked than
the other I couldn't open one of them
okay I'm just hoping I don't get
quartered by those weird Dancy guys the
ballerinas from hell
ah huh yeah do it away yeah yeah hey
that takes so much effort not that one
okay you know when they're on I don't
need Alba now anywhere would I need to
open now and I don't need to overdoing
hmm
oh good the thumpy thump is back I was
wondering when that was gonna happen
because uh-oh
it's very worried about missing out on
their goddamn keys yes those are you
know I got AMRO I can kill those
bastards I must save this game is taking
me a long time but I'm gonna bomb it uh
Steve threw it through to the end
there's another key but look look I'm
I'm mashing the F button it takes like
13 no you got hell and you die I'll help
you with a bullet to the face but that's
about it let me reload my gun yeah yeah
ready for some of this bad boy
what Wow oh go why
good thing I saved
okay I'm back and now I don't I did not
lose my AMRO this time I'm gonna see
this [ __ ] game through to the end no
matter what don't do that to me
I got no health but I recall there were
like health packs or something somewhere
back here I'm gonna try to find one I
remember where I was but I remember it
was there and I'm gonna get it I'm gonna
try to patch myself up so oh I was over
there but I guess it got it already
uh-huh
don't do that you keep doing that I
don't want you to not damn it I knew I
know there was something here all right
you know what balls to the wall here we
go just finish this thumpy thumpy how I
missed you my old friend hello darkness
my old friend good to see you here again
I don't remember the last of the lyrics
god damn it I have another key but I
don't know where it goes oh yeah there
was the UH the other door the bloody
door why is it bloody don't you dig with
me I got a gun this time and if ready
come on gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
gimme gimme
oh come on ah the most I'm going key
commit key key mechanics are annoying as
they are that was just making them
impossible to pick up how do you have
that up in a game how do you mess that
up it's worked in other FPS creator
games alright I'm being I'm being a
little critical though I should well
it's you me why not
what an odd to stay with those eyes or
bullet holes I couldn't tell why
[ __ ] it [ __ ] it you know what yeah you
are you that of me you gonna be like
haha you remember back in the seventies
cousin sorry we're gonna have a dick
punching party at the developers house
dick [ __ ] party 2.0 except we're gonna
get like those big Hulk fists and we're
gonna just go to town
oh you're cross whoever made this guy
we're gonna pound you this is a mission
a dot is a good way you know what I'm
done with this I'm very done I'm very
much done good play get way to log very
much done I'd rather go home have a
biscuit album I mean is the biscuits
down though
thank you all so much for watching click
the empty more videos that I've done and
as always I will see you in the next
video
that's all
Oh
ah
oh crap